but you can you can strong all right you
can you can pick
you can do a sort of
claw hammer sort of thing there's a lot
of different variations
I suppose you could do weird stuff too
like you know saw it with a violin ball
or things like that to make sounds
all of those are different ways of make
doing that efficient quads with each
song that you listen to on the radio
it's all coming down to building blocks
like this fretboard and somebody
actually fretting a chord playing a
chord
like another chord
moving to another chord
that's what songs are made of everything
that you encounter can be made sense of
in terms of
these four causes